david you've mentioned before the idea
of police
having to live in the communities where
they are policing
do you think this should be made a
requirement so there's a couple
complications with that
when i gave my list of here's how police
should be reformed
one of the things i mentioned was
requiring
some portion of the police department to
live
where they are policing now if you think
of a really big city like new york city
you could be policing the bronx but
living in staten island and if you
understand
the sort of class and racial dynamics of
that
you might not think that that's
fantastic but
putting aside some specific examples i
think that the idea of requiring a
percentage of police
to live in the city where they are
working is a good idea the problems
include number one a lot of police
don't live where they police because
they can't afford it
and so if your paradigm is defunding
police
unfortunately defunding police is often
inconsistent
with requiring police to live where they
are policing and in fact
if you really want to do that you may
have to look at
maybe not salary increases but cost of
living
bonuses for police that are living
in some of the areas they police there's
a reason why lots of nypd
live 90 minutes out in new jersey or in
upstate new york or you know not upstate
but north of the city
or wherever and it's because they can't
afford to live in new york city so
that's something that has to be
um considered the other thing that i
think is
important is that the reason we want
police uh living in or
it's really the opposite it's more that
we want police
that already live where they are going
to be working
there's a number of reasons for that you
could be more likely to de-escalate
rather than escalate if you're policing
your own
community it would make you more
acquainted
with the dynamics of your city
in terms of better identifying what is a
threat and what isn't a threat and this
is not to excuse when police obviously
misbehave and
say something's a threat that obviously
is not after the fact in order to get
out of trouble
but understanding the dynamics of your
city
better would certainly be a really good
thing
and being integrated into the community
would be a really really good thing
the possible downsides would be are
police more at risk of retaliation
against themselves and their families if
they're known to live in the community
um is it um it
would that be something that we need to
think about could it lead to selective
enforcement because if you live in a
community and you police it
you develop relationships it could skew
your relationship where you are no
longer
dealing with the community objectively
depending on whether you know the people
or whether you don't
i think that those are relatively small
risks i think that the
idea of saying all police must live
where they are policing is impossible
but i do think that the idea of
requiring a certain percentage
and if you need to give them cost of
living in order to be able to afford it
i would actually be okay with that
because i do think it would dramatically
improve policing
now let's step back from this question
there's a different question
that we also need to talk about which is
regardless of whether police come from
in the community or out of the community
there is a self-selection bias for who
wants to be a police officer
and there's lots of liberal police
officers i'm not
saying that there aren't but on average
police are more culturally conservative
than the average population and that's
something that we need to think about as
well
so you maybe would be able to deal with
that for example if you have a liberal
city
that is overwhelmingly policed by rural
police officers who live in conservative
areas
an hour and a half outside of a city
okay you could fix some of that
political imbalance
by bringing in people who live in the
city but that's a bigger question that
police departments are going to have to
deal with the cultural conservatism of
police there's a self-selection bias
it exists in the military as well
doesn't mean there aren't left-wing
people in the military in fact joe biden
is now
leading among members of the military
but that has to be thought of as well
when we think about
where should those who police us live we
also have to think about these cultural
components
one of our sponsors today is surf shark
which is a premium vpn service they're
giving my audience
83 off a two-year plan plus
three extra months for free which all
comes out to about two bucks a month and
if you're not already using a vpn
service you really are opening yourself
up to
internet service providers logging and
selling your internet history
tech companies tracking what you do
online even government surveillance
surfshark is a vpn that helps protect
you from
all of those things by hiding your ip
address when you're browsing online
comes with a bunch of other great
features it's a company you can actually
trust with your privacy and you can
install surfsharkvpn on unlimited
devices
they never keep logs of your internet
activity and you can even use it to
stream shows and movies that are only
available in other countries
surf shark is giving my audience 83
off a two-year plan plus three extra
month
free so that comes out to just about two
dollars a month which is
almost nothing relative to the peace of
mind you will have while browsing online
just go to surfshark.deals
pacman i've put the link underneath this
video and make sure to use the coupon
code pacman